hello everybody my name is maya and i'm
a black female engineer i provide
content for new and aspiring software
engineers and today we are talking about
the key habits
of the best software engineers and these
are things that you learning to code or
being a new developer you should be
doing today today today so that it's not
as like you never want to like start a
good habit when you like need to you
know what i mean you don't like practice
it so that way when you like do have
that job and whatnot it's like boom she
has amazing practices amazing habits
let's keep her on the team so the first
one is asking for
help this is something that i have
struggled with for a very long
time and i still struggle with i kind of
just like do it scared and do it
uncomfortable and like do it insecure um
but yeah asking for help when you need
it now that being said because in this
field you're constantly learning there's
not been a day where i have you know
clocked into work and i haven't come out
learning something new and that's
because the world of tech in the world
of computers and programming is just so
huge
and the problems and tasks that we are
handed there's sometimes like just maybe
a little something maybe a big something
that we just don't know and so we need
to be okay asking for help that being
said though i recommend staying in that
uncomfortable spot of the not knowing
for a little bit before you ask for help
because when you go ahead and ask for
help immediately after getting a task
you never really like grew you just got
told the answer rather than seeing all
these different answers seeing how to
problem solve learning how to debug and
whatnot and then after all that time at
least a few hours going and asking for
help and yes you may just be given the
answer however you still learned a lot
through that process of debugging and
researching on google and things like
that that in itself is a big learning
process knowing how to find answers and
so i recommend kind of like struggling a
little bit before you just go on and ask
for help but yeah you gotta be
comfortable asking for other people's
assistance number two you need to be
able to have a little bit of foresight
when you are coding so
let's say you get this assignment and
you yeah code it out have it all put
together however it's not considering
certain conditions like okay well what
if two people are using the app at the
same time or what if
x y and z happens like you need to be
able to kind of put in different
cases different scenarios and
adjust your code based on what may or
may not happen with these different
scenarios because yeah your code works
right now but what about one month now
or about two months from now when x y
and z has changed so make sure before
you send things up for review or before
you call it a day on your assignments
you're thinking like okay what if this
happens or if this happens and just put
up a list of like different use cases
and try to think like okay well you know
maybe maybe i can
adjust this code so that even though
this thing isn't a problem right now so
that in the future it can stay running
smoothly and why not because you're
gonna have to address it anyway you know
you're because two months from now even
if you like let's say wrap it all up and
everything's approved two months from
now people are still gonna come to you
and be like hey
it's not working properly and then you
need to adjust anyway so you're just
saving yourself time and a headache and
actually also showing that like okay i
was able to jump on this and again is
that constant practice being able to
practice that foresight setting up
things for the future will go a long way
number three i am actively
practicing this i think i've gotten
better and that's staying calm amidst
all the chaos and when i say chaos i
don't necessarily mean
actual chaos of the office or things
running around but just going through
code and going through your assignments
it can feel like chaos and you see all
these like bugs just coming on and it's
like oh my gosh like wow like it's so
easy to get all ramped up and just not
feel settled and everything and so being
able to stay calm or miss all that chaos
will save you so
so much so much stress and honestly time
also because a lot of times i'm because
i'm just like i don't know what to do i
end up just like
shutting down basically and so being
able to find ways to cope and stay calm
amidst all the chaos oh my gosh like
oh my gosh please please
work on this something that has helped
me is just simply reminding myself that
hey one
this is just like this is work you know
like there's a bug here there's two bugs
here there's going to be a bike tomorrow
and one tomorrow and the next day and
the next day and so on
so like remembering that like okay this
this is just the life i signed up for
like that helps because then it makes it
a part of the normal day rather than
like
something that shouldn't happen when i
when considering things like buds and
errors it's like it's not that something
that shouldn't happen just part of the
normal day and just like go through it
and that's the job description and so
remembering that actually helps me a ton
so figure out what things need to tell
yourself to stay calm amidst the storm
of it all and that'll help it down then
lastly the best software engineers are
ones that don't shy away from
collaboration there's this like
and i get it i get why people perceive
software engineers this way but this
whole this was the word image i guess
you could say of you know the closed off
developer who has their earphones in and
don't doesn't talk to anybody they're
terrible at communication they can't
talk to people and
and i get it again even saying i'm like
i unders there is there are those people
but the best like truly truly the best
software engineers are ones that don't
shy away from collaboration because
that's what helps you the most and also
helps the unit you're in the company the
team the most because with this
knowledge share again software
engineering and programming tech is just
so large that there's no one person that
knows everything but by you having that
collaboration with your team members and
other people you're putting in your two
knowledge like your two backgrounds and
tech experience together to create a
beautiful solution a fantastic creative
um solution for the task you're trying
to accomplish and now you have a piece
of their knowledge they have a piece of
yours and you are better developers for
it and so make sure that it's very easy
to fall into like even me saying it i
know i can fall into that wormhole of
like you know i'm just gonna like go go
go but then don't shy away from
collaboration of course it can be scary
of like okay well i don't want to like
ask dumb questions so i don't want x y
and z but see point number one um and
like just in general sometimes you're
just like lord just get me through the
day like i don't want to talk to anybody
that's how you get it but embrace those
opportunities when they do come to you
so make sure to keep remembering that
and keep practicing that no matter what
level you are in there we go everybody
the top habits of successful and amazing
wonderful software engineers let me know
what phase you are in in your journey to
becoming a software engineer if you are
still learning are you like new are you
50 years in and everything like let me
know in the comments below and i will
talk to you all later bye y'all